- I heard that you don't
actually watch scary movies.
- [Jamie] Oh please.
- I don't.
I don't, you do?
- I hate them.
I scare easily.
- Me too.
- As a child, I scared easily.
And I think it's probably
what makes me a good actress
in these films,
(Kelly laughs)
because I'm just genuinely
terrified all the time.
And I, you know, if we had more time,
I'd pull up a picture of me as
an infant and you'd be like,
"Oh wow," because I looked
startled and terrified.
- Oh my God.
I'm the same way.
I hate it.
I don't like to be jumped out at.
- No, no, no, no.
I startle easily.
- Oh yeah, I don't do...
What are those called?
The haunted houses?
- No.
- I don't do those.
- No,
- Who would go into a haunted house?
- It is a lawsuit waiting to happen.
I saw a raise of hands.
She's like, "I would."
- Who did?
But why?
- But I want to hit them.
Somebody jumps out at me...
Look, it's my reaction.
I'm ready.
You shouldn't jump out at me.
- No, no, no.
I'm not down with it.
- Okay.
You traveled with your parents
when they were on movie sets.
First of all, I'm asking,
did that mess you up?
Because my kids come to set a lot.
(Kelly laughs)
You had a good childhood, right?
- Well.
- Okay.
(Kelly laughs)
I always ask-
- Yes, it was fine.
It was fine, it was good.
Everything's good.
- I always worry.
I'm like, "Should I have
my kids around a lot?"
I'm always wondering-
- You know what?
They love being with you.
- Okay, okay, okay.
- They love you.
- Did you get into
trouble, though, on set?
Did you ever-
- Well, movie sets are
a nightmare to visit,
because you do this the entire time.
- Oh, exactly.
Yeah.
- You have to be silent.
- Yeah.
- It's terrible as a child.
- Okay.
- I think what you're referring to is
that there is a picture of me.
My dad did a movie in South
America called "Taras Bulba".
Tony Curtis made a movie and I,
that little girl right there.
So cute.
- I love camping.
- Except until the day
that Tony's driver was playing with me,
threw me up in the air and missed me.
(Kelly gasps)
And I ended up with a...
There was a picture of me
and I'm like a little girl
with a little sling.
I know.
- Oh wow.
- Hey, sets are dangerous.
Look, I'm in horror films.
Believe me.